So computer architecture is about building future
computers, and let's see how it interacts with
technology trends. So, progress in computer manufacturing technology
is very fast. So if we design with
current technology and using the parts we already
have for a computer, by the time we
design the new computer, we have an obsolete
new computer. Why? Well because, by the time
we have designed it with current technology and parts,
the technology and the pieces for computers have improved,
so what we have is something that is using
obsolete technology and obsolete components. So we must anticipate
future technology and what will be available, and then
when we design computer that way, we get future
computers that actually use the most advanced technology available
at that time. But how do we do that?
We must be aware of technology trends. That is, how do we expect technology to
change in the future, and what do we expect to be available in the future?